so oder philipp hat ja also sagte ich
versuche ja
also
neuer mitbewohner seit ein paar tagen
mehr hat er erzählte ich von klein auf
kennt
ach so
vielleicht hat er das gesagt weil wir
uns so gut verstehen als werden wir
zusammen aufgewachsen
ein herz und eine seele
hast du schon mal gekellnert nein
aber das ist bestimmt nicht so schwer
eine fc spielt um ein karnevalist ist
der ausnahmezustand
aber auch dann gilt freundlich sein das
ist das a und o
freundlichkeit also lächeln kann ich
überhaupt nicht
ich komme und bekomme ich den job ich
rufe dich an
man muss war das für ein seltsames
vorstellungsgespräch
ich brauche unbedingt einen
praktikumsplatz wenn er auch noch
bezahlt wäre müsste ich nicht um einen
kellner job betteln
du kannst doch taxifahrer mittlerweile
kennst du dich heraus sehr lustig aus
den einbahnstraßen hier in köln weil ich
wohl nie schlau werden
aber das praktikum ist jetzt auch viel
wichtiger auch mark ich habe mich
überall beworben und immer nur absagen
gekriegt und immer heißt es für die
nächsten zwei jahre haben wir keine
freien plätze mehr wert ist sicher
früher kümmern müssen
du sagst ausgerechnet du der trotz aller
versprechungen seinen hintern nicht
hochkriegen dafür ist mein hintern sexy
ich verstehe wirklich nicht magst
einfach faul was er braucht ist ein
ordentlicher tritt in den hintern
das schlimme ist wenn ich das praktikum
nicht bis nächstes alles noch schlimmer
du kannst dir nicht vorstellen wie
bescheuert diese behörden in düsseldorf
sind was ich für anträge ausfüllen muss
mein dekanat um ein gewerbe beim
gewerbeamt anzumelden brauche ich ein
formular von der industrie und
handelskammer
so geht das die ganze zeit erst wenn das
finanzamt dann will der vermieter eine
bürgschaft an das arbeitsamt da nicht
hat vielleicht liegt es daran dass
kölner und düsseldorfer sich nicht
leiden können ich bin jedenfalls
ziemlich genervt da geht es dir bin mir
aber bevor ich mit alex evans groß
rauskommen und millionen verdienen muss
ich mich durchkämpfen